By sun needs some orthodontic work done and I wondered if metal braces or
visoline is the better option. Is there one that is less toxic to have it as
most? Well, I think the visoline is less toxic. It's a plastic tray, but I think
you're getting less toxins from that than you're getting from metal braces.
The reason is the metal braces is stainless steel that's only done to your teeth with
a clamp. You have to use a paste that is going to basically cement them onto the
teeth. So there's toxins that are involved with that. That means said there
are sometimes that the visoline will work for people. So you have to talk to
multiple different orthodontics to see what is going to be best for that person's
mouth because you know depending on what is needed to be done if it's a widened
palate if you might need to get an expander beforehand. There's just lots of
different things that go on with that. I'm not going to give advice about
orthodontic work, but from a toxicity level I think you're better off with the
visoline.